ja abseits von
energiepolitischen Fragen braut sich in
Deutschland in meinen Augen gerade auch
durch die Migration in den vergangenen
Jahren ein Thema zusammen wir sehen im
Iran den Freiheitskampf der Frauen die
dafür kämpfen dass sie das erste Mal in
ihrem Leben das Kopftuch ablegen können
ohne dafür verhaftet und im Gefängnis zu
landen wir sehen die Unruhen und jetzt
wird natürlich auch in Deutschland
diskutiert es wirft aber ein Schlaglicht
auf die Debatte die wir in Deutschland
bislang nicht geführt haben nämlich die
Frage warum eigentlich in Deutschland
zunehmend Mädchen und Frauen mit
Kopftuch herumlaufen und wann wir
endlich anfangen uns mit diesen
hausgemachten Problemen zu befassen ich
denke es ist an der Zeit dass wir das
was wir dem Ausland immer erklären und
das was wir unter feministischer
Außenpolitik erklären dass wir das auch
im Inland anwenden und dass wir ein
Kopftuchverbot jetzt brauchen auch für
die Schulen in Deutschland und für die
Verwaltung um dieses politische Symbol
dass man zunehmend sieht und dann immer
jüngeren Frauen und jüngeren Mädchen man
sieht teilweise Grundschulmädchen
inzwischen mit Kopftüchern dass wir hier
in unserem Land genauso für die Freiheit
und für die Selbstbestimmungsrecht der
Frau kämpfen müssen auch gegen einen
zugewanderten Islam wie wir bereit wären
das Wort zu ergreifen für die Frauen im
Iran
Herr grub wie empfinden Sie es das sind
Schulen in der Verwaltung Kopftuch
getragen werden darf gut für mich ist
das noch nie nachvollziehbar gewesen
dass ich sage ich gebe einem Asyl und
lass ihn hier reinkommen und dann muss
ich mich an ihn nach seinen Vorschriften
richten wenn einer zu mir zu Gast kommt
hat er sich nach meinen Vorschriften zu
richten ansonsten ist noch nicht mein
Gast und das war für mich immer
uniskutabel dass wir sagen der Kopftuch
und da ist das und da wollen wir
Moscheen und das und so weiter ich hätte
das von Anfang an hätte ich das verlangt
wenn einer beim bei uns wohnen will und
hier
einwandern will dann muss er sich auch
an unsere Gewohnheiten richten so wie
ich mich selbstverständlich auch im
Ausland danach richte wie die das wollen
und und wie dir das haben ob das in
Japan ist oder das in Amerika ist und
ich richte mich auch in der Schweiz
danach dass man wesentlich langsamer
fahren darf als in Deutschland dürfte
man bei Trigema mit Kopftuch Arbeiten
der Gruppe ich das ist dort wird mit
Kopftuch gearbeitet ja aber es wird
vorgeschrieben dass es nicht störend
nicht stört und so weiter und Verschlag
ganz verschleiert gibt's nicht das ist
untersagt aber es ist für uns ja
schwierig wenn es allgemein sozusagen
gestartet ist dass ich dann sage bei mir
im Betrieb gestatte ich das nicht weil
wir haben 20 25 Nationalitäten und das
sind eben auch solche dabei und ich sag
mal und das was der Staat zulässt dann
selbst zu verbieten das wäre für uns
schwierig aber ich hätte es begrüßt wenn
von vornherein gesagt hätte so muss es
hier ablaufen denn ich persönlich finde
das auch nicht in Ordnung und ich sage
mal ich trage ja auch wenn ich im
Ausland bin ich sag mal als ich ein
Saudi-Arabien zum ersten Mal war mit
meiner frisch eingehaarten Frau dann
durfte sie nicht ins Schwimmbad weil das
nur für Männer reserviert war das hat
sie selbstverständlich akzeptiert sie
musste Kopftuch tragen weil das
selbstverständlich so war wir haben uns
dort nichts dabei gedacht wir haben uns
an das gehalten was das Land
vorgeschrieben hat weil wir das schätzen
und weil wir die Leute auch dann gesagt
haben wenn die das so wollen dann machen
wir die Frage die ich mir stelle ist
warum man überhaupt denn solche Länder
fährt oder sich dort anpasst also ich
würde die ich würde dir ich würde die
moralische Frage noch viel größer
aufmachen weil wir sind ja ganz
großartig im moralisieren auch in
Deutschland das heißt wenn wir von
Schurken kein Gas kaufen warum finden
Sie noch nie außerhalb in der Moschee
beispielsweise ich bin dein Kopftuch ein
nein
also ich muss ja nicht zwingend irgendwo
reingehen wo man mich wo man mich zwingt
ein Kopftuch zu tragen sondern ich finde
da fängt genau die Prinzipien sollten
die Prinzipien anfangen und wenn ich
dann jetzt sehe jetzt beklagen die
Grünen hier und jetzt hören wir Grüne
stimmen ja wir müssen jetzt das Kopftuch
im im Iran und wir sind stehen mit
Solidarität ich erinnere mich noch gut
an die Fotos von Claudia Roth wie sie
mit Kopftuch im Iran stand auf ihren
Besuchen das heißt erhöht sich teilweise
freiwillig in Kopftücher wir haben wir
erleben gerade auch in bei den bei den
linken Parteien eine unglaublich absurde
Debatte man kämpft hier in Deutschland
von auch feministischer Seite dafür auch
für das Recht auf Kopftuch tragen
während auf der anderen Seite der Welt
die die Frauen die feministischen Frauen
fragen wo seid ihr im Westen um uns zu
unterstützen weil für uns ist das
Kopftuch das Symbol der Unterdrückung
das heißt wir wir führen hier Luxus
Debatten die völlig abwegig sind und
reden das Kopftuch schön und das kann
man nun sagen wir machen
ich glaube das luxusdebatte viele Frauen
in Deutschland auch die es vielleicht
freiwillig sich dazu entscheiden und das
zum Beispiel bei der Arbeit bei Trigema
tragen möchten wenn Sie das als
luxusdebatte beschreiben glaube ich
würden sie auch manche Frauen einfach
beleidigen und verletzen ich würde sagen
ich würde gerne zu einem
gesellschaftlichen Zustand kommen ich
würde ihnen übrigens recht geben in der
Frage bei erwachsenen Frauen da muss man
durchaus unterscheiden es gibt die
Frauen die erwachsenen Frauen die
tatsächlich das Kopftuch gerne tragen
wollen ich möchte sich sicherstellen die
Freiwilligkeit auch in Deutschland und
mit Verlaub ich sehe selbst im
Schwimmbad Kinder Mädchen die quasi noch
völlig noch nicht einmal am Ansatz der
Pubertät sind die inzwischen quasi mit
ganzkörperkleidung in deutschen
Freibädern auftauchen ich sehe Mädchen
die komplett verschleiert sind bis auf
das Gesicht die noch schon vor der
Pubertät bei uns auch im ländlichen Raum
sieht man diese Mädchen ich zweifle
einfach an dass hier eine Freiwilligkeit
vorausgesetzt werden kann und ich möchte
gerne dass wir als freiheitliche
Demokratie sicherstellen vehement
das auf diese Mädchen frei groß werden
und sich freiwillig dafür entscheiden
können und diese Freiwilligkeit ist
nicht gegeben hier würde ich gerne
einmal Herrn Brüderle fragen wie sie auf
die Debatte blicken ich hatte den Ansatz
für falsch ich bin gegen Zwang aber eine
Frau freiwilligen Kopftuch tragen will
kann sie das Jude keine Kipper tragen in
Deutschland ist ein gutes Recht
katholische Schwester kann auch eine
entsprechende kopfkleidung betragen ich
habe einen wahlkämpf das gelbe fdp-kappe
getragen so mein gutes Recht und wir
lösen die Probleme im Iran nicht wenn
man hier
Mechanismen einführen das eine Frau die
es vielleicht freiwillig will die hat
ein anderes Empfinden als unseres dabei
ein Soles Kopftuch trägt dann soll sie
es machen mich stört das nicht ich finde
gegen ein Zwang keiner in Deutschland
gezogen Kopftuch zu tragen ist keiner
gezwungene Kipper zu tragen das ist
alles freiwillig Entscheidung ist auch
keine gezwungene Nonnentracht durch die
Gegend zu tragen ist alles hier
freiwillig Entscheidung und wir helfen
den Problemen im Iran 0 also wir solche
Mechanismen
sagen konnte
im Schwimmbad freiwillig machen
vielleicht noch eine Sittenpolizei in
Deutschland schwimmen will er das machen
ich bin dagegen
Zwangsmechanismen einzuführen bei uns
dann sehen wir auf der gleiche Stufe die
anderen wenn der freie Entscheidung so
ist okay
bei der Debatte um den Iran vor allem
dass es Politiker gibt ja auch in
Spitzenämtern in absoluten Spitzenämtern
in diesem Land die eigentlich dem
müller-regime immer wieder auch sehr
devot gegenüber aufgetreten sind
gratuliert haben wenn es irgendwas
angeblich zu gratulieren gab da hat eine
Demokratie was das angeht wirklich
versagt hat sich zu einem ja duckmäuse
gegenüber einem totalitären Regime
gemacht das ist eigentlich meine ich
anpranger in dem Fall ist es Steinmeier
der einfach gratuliert zu einem
Jahrestag eines totalitären Regimes wie
wir im Iran sehen dass Frauen
unterdrückt und zwar auf brutalste Art
und Weise und das ist das was ich jetzt
in dieser kurzen Zeit gerne sehr sehr
Schäfer heute der Schlusswort wir sind
am Ende der Sendung angekommen ich hoffe
es hat ihnen auch so viel Spaß gemacht